[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance this extraordinary sourced
quote from Trump was put out by Mike
Allen of Axios comm co-founder of
Politico at 8 o'clock on a Saturday
morning the Trump quote is so stark so
shattering so unprecedented that in fact
it should have been saved for noon on a
weekday and have been preceded by a
whistle loud enough to be heard by
everybody in the nation commanding them
to stop what they were doing and
listened to it a Trump advisor says that
after a tumultuous seven months in
office it had finally dawned on the
president quote people really effing
hate me Donald Trump and I agree on
something you and I know people really
epping hate Trump we are some of the
people who do but this at nearly eight
months into his presidency more than 71
years into his life is apparently the
first time it or anything like it has
gotten through to the future
ex-president himself it had finally
dawned on the president people really
effing hate me for someone who has spent
his life lapping up adulation
however fake it was a harsh realization
this is a man with an especially acute
need for affirmation no kidding
this revelation explains Trump's entire
existence and Trump's recent otherwise
inexplicable Accords with Democratic
leaders like Chuck Schumer and Nancy
Pelosi and it even provides cover for
Democrats and others who see the
necessity of removing what a Fox poll
showed 60% of us agree is an unstable
man from the White House while Muller
slowly builds his case while Trump's
popularity sinks and at least some
Republicans begin to be faced with the
choice of repudiating him or not getting
reelected while his connection to
reality continues to fray while all that
happens everybody can just soft soap
Trump Trump has had a moment of reality
worthy of a Shakespearean tragic hero
that light
flash of self-awareness that we effing
hate him and thus we may be able to
continue to play him like Schumer and
Pelosi did like the proverbial
two-dollar banjo to minimize further
damage to the very fabric of human
civilization and the political
conventional wisdom again rushes to
reassure itself that its cliches still
work that he's pivoting in some way that
he's suddenly a cross-party pragmatist
that he's an independent that he's a bla
bla bla bla bla nonsense he's right this
time we people just really effing hate
him may I remind you of the headlines of
the last six weeks after the Nazis and
the KKK rallied in Virginia Trump made a
boilerplate statement about blame on
many sides then come issued a generic
statement that somebody else wrote then
Trump repudiated that statement in a
news conference of uncontrolled rage in
which he shouted about how both sides
were equally guilty then Trump held a
rally at which he read back his first
statement but left out the part about
many sides Trump threatened North Korea
with fire and fury Trump threatened
South Korea economically Trump
threatened Venezuela Trump went back and
threatened North Korea again Trump
pardoned Joe Arpaio Trump said he
pardoned our paio during a hurricane
because the TV ratings would be higher
Trump tweeted during the first hurricane
plugging a book by another infamous now
former sheriff Trump men tweeted during
the hurricane about building a wall to
keep out people of the same heritage as
a huge percentage of the victims of the
hurricane Trump traveled to Texas twice
during that hurricane the first time he
saw neither a victim nor a storm Trump
demanded tax cuts for rich people to be
speeded up because of the second
hurricane Trump referred to the Coast
Guard during the second hurricane as a
quote brand that has quote improved
Trump was repudiated about civil rights
by his own secretary of state Trump was
repudiated about transgender rights by
his own Secretary of Defense Trump was
repudiated about anti-semitism
by his own chairman of the White House
Economic Council Trump was so mad at the
chairman of his White House Economic
Council that he reportedly refused to
make eye contact with him
Trump's former senior adviser said in a
TV interview that any senator or
congressman who voted to impeach Trump
would be endangering their own lives and
that there would be a civil war Trump
reneged on the promise of daca blamed
Congress and then made a vague promise
to the dreamers in a tweet Trump turned
out to reportedly have written a first
draft of a letter justifying the firing
of the FBI director for not clearing him
on Russia Trump turned out to have at
least weighed in and maybe just wrote
the untrue statement issued by his own
son about a meeting his son had with
middlemen his son believed were giving
him Russian government dirt on Hillary
Clinton that's all just in the last six
weeks one would think that even in the
warped minds of those who think all that
was good news there is one basic human
emotion enough already I am exhausted I
want to watch something else in my life
besides Trump the key thing about tragic
heroes from the plays of the ancient
Greeks through Shakespeare is that they
all have that moment of Revelation that
epiphany of Lord what have I done
the people effing hate me but from
Oedipus to Hamlet it has to come too
late to make any difference
and usually the tragic hero is still not
getting some of the message that the
universe is sending him thus if the
Trump quote presidency unquote is
classic tragedy then the quote that
Axios attributed to a trump advisor was
necessarily missing a couple of words it
isn't people really effing hate me it's
we the people really effing hate you
resist remove peace my new book of these
commentaries and other writings which I
really should have called people really
effing hate him is available for
pre-order and will be out October 17th I
know I know I just said even those who
like Trump are exhausted by him I am too
just buy the book and wait for him to go
and
read it a couple of months after that
Thanks